mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschen ihnen viel vergnügen
aus allen richtungen strömen sie herbei
mitglieder des jugendsinfonieorchesters
zürich und des tonhalle orchesters
zürich
sie versammeln sich mitten in der stadt
um bolero zu spielen doch es gibt eine
hürde das konzert beginnt bloß falls
jemand sie spontan dirigiert
denn er der profi hält sich heute zurück
[Musik]
wir sind beide mit zufällig der dort
besinnt
[Musik]
ich bin eigentlich schon gespannt und
neugierig und deswegen warten bis
endlich was ziel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im rat
[Musik]
wir kommen ja heute heute begleiten wir
ein experiment das züricher jugend sind
von ihr sie hier
ein ungewohnter ordnung ein konzert zu
geben
doch ungewohnten dass sie dieses
experiments dirigieren soll das
orchester kein profi sondern singt oder
ich also von innen oder was an sich ja
mehr noch den taktstock zu schwingen und
nette typen hier das wollen wir sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es war wirklich toll ich hatte viel
blickkontakt mit dem schlagzeuger der da
saß und mir große aufmerksamkeit
schenkte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr boksic bisher direkt die hand an
der kapazitätsgrenze und was sollen mit
madoff in new york gleich mit zu
unsicher das ist pole das ist super
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wusste nicht wie anfangen ich musste
mich stoppen
[Musik]
es ist natürlich kein zufall dass das
orchester das stück bolero von maurice
ravel ausgesucht hat es ist eines der
bekanntesten stücken der klassischen
musik überhaupt und auch längst ein
stück popkultur aus kind der 80er jahre
denke ich bei bolero natürlich vor allem
auch an die verführungskünste von bo
derek wir gehen der faszination
belehrung nach
es ist wohl das erotischste crescendo
der musikgeschichte
ihm fehlen 10 die traumfrau untermalte
bolero eine bettszene mit bo derek und
erlangte auch fernab von klassik kreisen
berühmtheit
gott bist du kannst musst du wieder von
vorne anfangen was die platte musste
wieder von vorne fliegen
der bolero sport paare zur
höchstleistung
so auch bei den olympischen spielen 1984
in sarajevo
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese verschmelzung von sport und musik
verzückt das publikum und die jury
gleichermaßen neun mal eine sechs- bis
heute ein einmaliges ereignis
und wer hat gesagt dass der legendäre
frank zappa die stücke gecovert habe bei
seiner rockband uhr
1988 inszeniert und intonierte er den
bolero auf seine weise
[Musik]
warum ist dieses werk so universell
und warum fasziniert es laien wie musik
kennerinnen stets aufs neue
sff musikredakteur benjamin herzog hat
sich intensiv mit dem bolero
auseinandergesetzt
oliver hat die ganz einfache struktur
jeden sofort gelüftet der cholera wird
vor in jedem orchester gespielt cholera
wird in jedem musikunterrichts die
kinder vorgeführt und das runter zur
uraufführung in paris jetzt auch die 20
skandal erregte
also wenn das stück ganz gleich
angefangen hat hat es vielleicht nie die
popularität erreicht was hütte hat seit
damals schon ärger
für den knall sorgt die russische mäzen
in ida rubinstein
sie tanzten bolero bei der uraufführung
1928 in der pariser oper als einzige
frau und ein kreis vor 20 männer davon
gibt es keine aufnahmen viele
tänzerinnen neben später jedoch diese
uhr kryptographie wieder auf wie etwa
die französin sylvie gehen
2015 an einer neujahrskonzert in tokio
im paris der 20er jahre begeistert und
schockiert ida rubinstein mit ihren
erotischen bewegung
[Musik]
es geht da nicht drohte das wärmste
aufführung dem publikum eine frau
schreit hilfe verrückter
und das travel später trainer im
gespräch sei
die hec begriffe der französische
komponist maurice ravel ist bekannt für
seine ironischen art er soll mal gesagt
haben ich habe nur ein meisterwerk
geschaffen das ist der bolero nur leider
in täter keine musik
tatsächlich ist das stück zu beginn eine
provokation für die klassikwelt ravel
nimmt den spanischen tanz bolero aus dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert daher auch der
name seines werks und welt den
dreivierteltakt als basis
über diesen rhythmus lässt er 18 mal
zwei sich wiederholende melodien spielen
nach und nach kommen immer mehr
instrumente hinzu ein radikal durch
gezogenes crescendo und ein gefundenes
fressen für temperamentvolle dirigenten
wie sergiu celibidache hier mit
dänemarks radiosinfonieorchester
oder herbert von karajan
1985 mit den berliner philharmonikern
und natürlich auch gustavo dudamel im
schlusskonzert des lucerne festivals
2010 mit den wiener philharmonikern
[Musik]
schauen wir noch glück bei uns im system
es geht es 300 aufnahme vom boulevard
also das ist ja nicht so viele wie es
vor der fünften sinfonie von beethoven
geht und fast doppelt so viel wie vor
der kleine nachtmusik mozart unglaublich
und wird eine 350 optionen also nicht
für einen klassischen orchester gespielt
das gibt es gitarren quartett quintett
es gibt katharina valente war
schubert i button der
xo sache also einmal und volumen
minute
außerhalb europas ist die version von
angelique kidjo wohl am berühmtesten der
bolero heißt london
und das hong kong ballett inszeniert vor
zwei jahren den bolero in moderner
manier zum eigenen vierzigsten
geburtstag
[Musik]
für benjamin herzog bleibt die
klassische version aber die
faszinierendste
das stück ghetto viertelstunde und die
viertelstunde lang ist in täglicher
tonart und kurz vor schluss rückte die
tonart klappe des autoritär zofe also
verrutscht sie und das macht diesen
effekt du bist ritzer minute ca im
gleichen grieche monatlicher gewässer
und der plötzlich verrutschte wird eine
verdichtung ein anderer schüttelt und
dann ist er bereit für die große knall
im finale
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jascha von der goltz sie haben heute
nachmittag aus dirigieren das
jugendsinfonieorchester hier begleitet
haben sie dann auch talente entdeckt im
publikum ja absolut also es war mit
sicherheit der ein oder andere dabei der
wirklich das zeug hätte sich da vorne
hin zu stehen es war besonders
interessant zu sehen wie sich einige
mehr trauen wirklich das spektrum
auszuweiten mal was auszuprobieren was
verrücktes und andere dann doch bei
schlichteren interpretationen geblieben
was braucht dann ein guter dirigent
ich würde sagen multitasking ist das
wichtigste denn man muss nicht nur das
orchester dirigieren nur gute technik
haben gut vorbereitet sein die partitur
in und auswendig kennt sondern man muss
auch spontan seien bereit sein von
seinen plänen abzuweichen und man
braucht auch ein unheimlich feines
gespür für seine zwischen menschen weil
jeder einzelne musiker ja gut
ausgebildet ist und nicht als
teil einer gruppe nur angesehen werden
will jetzt hat es ja heute nachmittag
trotz den dilettanten und dilettanten
die wir alle sind wenn wir auf dem
podest stehen ganz gut geklungen also es
hat nicht nur nach katzenmusik gelungen
heißt das der dirigent ist doch auch ein
wenig obsolet überflüssig
die ansicht kann man vertreten es gibt
ja auch genug orchester die ohne
dirigenten spielen und es funktioniert
und die proben nicht mit einem
dirigenten vorher sondern die können das
auch so es gibt allerdings repertoire wo
es wirklich noch nötig ist einen
dirigenten vorne stehen zu haben und ich
denke die meisten orchester wünschen
sich jemand der die verantwortung
übernimmt der entscheidungen trifft und
der dem orchester ein gutes gefühl gibt
und dafür sind wir denke ich da ist denn
polio ein solches stück das den
dirigenten zwingend braucht das ist
wahrscheinlich eines der stücke die ganz
sicher keinen dirigenten braucht es
braucht einen guten schlagzeuger und
damit hat sich die sache eigentlich ist
wenn sie jetzt vor dem
jugendsinfonieorchester stehen gelten
andere regeln wie bei einem gestandenen
orchester mit sicherheit also es hat
sowohl vorteile als auch nachteile würde
ich jetzt nicht sagen aber zum einen
sind die kinder würde ich mal sagen
viel enthusiastischer und sind wirklich
wollen alles geben und sind bereit über
grenzen hinweg zu gehen und mit
profimusikern da findet man dieses
phänomen aber auch noch oft aber man
kann sich mehr arbeit sparen mit profi
orchestern weil man auf einem höheren
level anfängt und dann an detail
arbeiten arbeiten muss sie studieren
selbst noch orchesterleitung und
natürlich der hochschule der künste was
sind denn die grundpfeiler einer solchen
ausbildung also ich würde sagen hier in
zürich sind die grundpfeiler vor allem
praxis praxis platzes wir haben das
privileg dass wir hier unheimlich viel
zeit mit kleineren aber auch großem
ensemble verbringen können und kein
dirigent ist gut bevor er nicht eine
gewisse erfahrung gesammelt hat über
jahre hinweg und das ist das wichtigste
und dazu kommt natürlich theoretische
fächer gehörbildung harmonielehre und
solche
[Musik]
was ich das gefühl des kongo
ist die sexy
ja ich kaufe
ja und das ist schwierigsten 7
delegierte
der woodstock
holte willi kleine manchen slums
glücklich meine maschine sinfonie so
sollen
also völlig verflogen und die vielen
privaten vorsorge
[Musik]
als lee komme
ich an zwei ganz große musik kam ist
schluss schnitzen und das ist die größte
was ich je getan
ja in der tat bereit das ist schwierig
das jugendsinfonieorchester ist
musikalischer juniorpartner der tonhalle
zürich und diese wurde in den letzten
vier jahren aufwändig renoviert nun ist
sie feierlich wieder eröffnet mit einem
neuen prunkstück in großen konzerthallen
wir stellen vor
[Musik]
knapp 5000 pfeifen 69 register rund 25
tonnen gewicht
sie ist die königin unter den
instrumenten die neue orgel im frisch
renovierten konzertsaal der tonhalle
zürich
rückblende vor einem jahr in der
orgelbau fabrik co die traditionsreiche
firma im zürcherischen männedorf hat die
orgel gefertigt genauso wie schon die
allererste für die tonhalle
1872 das ganze tonhalle projekt hat für
uns historische wichtig dass wir wieder
der vermieter orgel die summe
weltberühmte konzert sein sich natürlich
riesig
heute machen sich ein paar ausgewählte
orgelpfeifen auf wanderschaft
von männedorf nach zürich per schiff
ganz so wie in früheren zeiten als das
unternehmen die fracht immer per schiff
transportierte
am ankunft hafen dann großer bahnhof für
das kostbare gut alle honoratioren sind
hier zum empfang ganz besonders freut
sich chefdirigent paavo järvi
früher stellte man es nie infrage dass
eine konzerthalle eine orgel haben
sowie eine kirche eine orgel haben muss
es ist äußerst wichtig dass die tonale
eine hochwertige orgel besitzt sonst
können wir viele repertoire
die orgel ist schließlich die königin
der instrumente und eine neue halle
verdient eine gute ordnung
im august 2020 ist der umbau der
tonhalle noch voll im gang und schwer
vorstellbar wie hier ein orgelkonzert
klingen wird
das ganze klang potenzial werden die
orgelbauer nun aus jeder einzelnen
pfeife herauskitzeln das schwierigste
ist dass man die akustik des raumes
möglichst schnell erfassen muss weil
jegliche frequenz lager an das
übertragen wird in einem raum und das
eigentlich für das musikalische erlebnis
eine große rolle spielt und dabei eine
rolle ja im grunde alle frequenzen
vorhanden sind die das menschliche gehör
hören kann ist das natürlich eine sehr
weite aufgabe
[Musik]
ein jahr später ist die aufgabe
praktisch erfüllt
also ich würde sagen bestimmte jetzt
sauber und danach noch zwei oboen töne
erstmal
[Musik]
da geht nicht an dass schießt ja das
habe ich aber jetzt in der hand dann
kann man das auch nicht hören wenn du es
in der hand teil ja
geh doch mal bitte mit dem finger dran
oktober stabil bleibt
[Musik]
zwölf monate lang haben günter böhme und
sein team tausende pfeifen intoniert und
gestimmt da entsteht eine besondere nähe
zum gefertigten
ich bin zu jedem instrument was wir
machen eine persönliche beziehung auf
und ich glaube auch ohne diese
persönliche beziehung würde man eine
bestimmte qualität nicht erreichen das
geht gar nicht also im grunde sind das
alle kinder alles kinder die man dann
entlässt in das leben und wo man auch
eine weile noch begleitet und schaut
sind jetzt gut ist dass stabil
funktioniert das ist das nachhaltig
gewesen was man macht
demnächst wird die orgel erstmals der
öffentlichkeit präsentiert für den
intonateur die feuertaufe
man strebt immer bestimmte punkte an die
man genau erreichen will und das ist
schon spannend ob man das ist es gibt
nie ein instrument was 100 prozent
gelungen ist also zumindest würde ich
das von mir behaupten es gibt ja immer
noch etwas was man noch besser machen
wollte wenn es dann ginge und aber das
ist auch anders herum betrachtet die
einzige chance dass man sich noch weiter
entwickelt ansonsten ist es wert dass
vergeblich
[Musik]
erich zumstein sie sind der direktor der
musikschule konservatorium zürich und
damit auch der oberste chef vom
jugendsinfonieorchester wie muss man
sich zusammen mit der tonhalle zürich
vorstellen zusammen ist so dass man mit
jugendlichen und tonmeister und eine
profi arbeitete für zusammen schaffen
und auch profis in registerproben erste
probe für aktivieren suchen sind von ihr
ist auch ein wunderbarer nachwuchs pool
für tonhalle des tonhalle orchesters hat
sie auf
links
das haben wir so wie sich natürlich
krise nachwuchsorchester sondern dem msv
duisburg wird gehen sie ins studium
bereich und zwar über den gegner
studieren und dann ist mit möglichkeit
in die tonhalle
2000 schüler und schülerinnen
das war geboten liefere mit umsatz und
lehrer versuchen wir das auch qualitativ
hohen levels bieten und diese
jugendlichen der stadt serie von vorwerk
zur musik zu bringen es spielen
mitglieder vom tonhalle orchester wobei
jahre älter sind wie die andere oder
schnitt ist das ist aber dass die
thermalbäder riskiert dass man die
profis dafür aktivieren mit dieser
jungen
erfahrungsschatz motivieren wenn sie vom
boden für musik und dass ich endlich der
lebensinhalt wo sie hand- und die
jugendlichen jetzt mitglieder vom
eigentlich jugendsinfonieorchesters
inzwischen 14 bis 24
also ein recht teures auto lässt hand
berufe wie aus dem ruf besonders
harmonisches professionellen
mittelpunkt stellt und die halt für den
abend mit der aktivität der mit
registerproben und szenisch musik und
der dirigent vorderwagen ist das
zusammenführt und ziel ist publikum mit
der musik
das ist so schwierig dass man viel
disziplin braucht viel probe braucht
aber die jugendlichen sind so motiviert
und im übrigen simponi stationiert mit
schaffen dass sich der aufwand lohnt für
das projekt spricht ihr
einige laie dirigentin dirigenten erlag
dr wir würden profitieren
unser motorrad und das instrumentarium
erlernt das sind stimmen und analysen
begabte begabungsförderung bis und pre
college und dann über musikhochschule
studieren und das erlangen das ist
bewusst aber irgendwann muss man ja von
uns probieren über perspektiven zu
erholen danke
[Musik]
man wird sehen was er gemacht habe
aufmerksam sind vor allem mit anderen
erlebt damals spiel zurückkam erhöht die
trommel kdh drückt ihr
alltag und dirigieren konzert nummer oft
harte fakten angaben zu 100 es kommt auf
die ganze körpersprache hoffe dass ich
die gleichstellungs und ich bin eine
fremde person mit der dynamik so dass
wir das personal habe man halt nicht und
dann war das machen und ich finde
[Musik]
das lustig sei deshalb extrem spaß
gemacht und mir nicht viel zu lachen
können wir das mit sicherheit
auch ein entdecker was eigentlich so
nicht alles ist und dass die erfahrung
gemacht es habe mehr spaß macht ja die
person hatte bis musikalisches in sich
[Musik]
unsere kolleginnen und kollegen von
radio sf2 kultur bieten jungen
musikschaffenden übrigens auch eine
bühne bis zum 19 september übertragen
sie täglich live ab 20 uhr ein konzert
vom nachwuchstalent und jetzt
dranbleiben das lohnt sich die
sternstunde musik zeigt gleich im
anschluss das eröffnungskonzert der
renovierten tonhalle zürich unter der
leitung von dirigent paavo järvi auch er
hat einmal klein angefangen der nächste
woche dann nehmen wir sie mit zur art
basel kommen sie gut dass die woche zu
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]